the white sox will be throwing the
right-hander ronaldo lopez at the east
today don't know how long he's going to
be able to go he worked three innings in
a start against the twins last week big
pull shift for the lefty matt olson the
three-hitter one pitch from lopez
fly ball left side alloy jimenez will
come in
and making routine play right at the
chest
the a's are retired one two three by
reynaldo lopez
a couple of pop outs and a fly out so
we'll head to the bottom of the first
still no score you certainly feel like
they have the right man on the mound
tonight chris bassett's been one of the
best pitchers in baseball and he's 12
and three in a 306 era here's cesar
hernandez who began the year with the
indians
he's batting 233 with 20 homers and 51
rbis abreu is on deck at the belt and
now the 3-2 pitch and that swung out a
miss a high-fast ball 92
brian goodwin is coming out
back to bass at all my goodness
oh boy
boy that ball was hit right up to him i
don't know exactly maybe in it let's
hope it's not
a blow to his head but it looks like it
might be yeah it does not look good wow
sean murphy immediately just
trying to get the training staff out
there as quickly as possible
when he is down and nick papp arrested
his head athletic trainer is out there
and
he went he went down he's down on the
front slope of the mound and that was a
a ball that was just hammered by goodwin
right back to him
and chris is face down
and now all our thoughts everybody at
the ballpark all of our thoughts
everybody there with the a's
right-hander
i mean just seeing bob melvin's reaction
looking down
there was some blood that he saw and
there immediately applied a towel to it
to the side of his head and that's all
we could tell at this point
it's and you think back to
you know brandon mccarthy here at the
coliseum against the los angeles angels
see nick paparesta the a's trainer
getting some help from
somebody from the white sox dugout as
well
as players kind of gathered around in
the grass and
they have a towel under his face now
offense and you can see the blood
there's quite a bit of blood
it's a
terrible moment unfolding
and they've brought the cart out onto
the field now and what's happening on
the field with the game is
is very much secondary right now
his outfielders and marty and cannon
harrison all have taken their hats off
when they're kneeling on the outfield
grass and now chris
he is he is conscious he's he's holding
he's now he's still
he's still sitting down on the front
slope of the mound
but he was able to kind of rise up and
you can see he's holding that towel
under his face
so an incredibly scary moment here in
chicago
and they're arresting him on the cart
and they'll be taking him off obviously
and
you're reminded how fragile things are
and how close you are to the plate when
you're a pitcher and you deliver a pitch
and the ball is hit like that right up
the middle
yeah it definitely got him on the the
right side of the face the white sox
will have the bases loaded and no one
out here in the bottom of the second no
score
andrew vaughan is your hitter
smith deals the 2-2 bond serves one out
in the right through the hole it'll
score one
joe mcewings waving mankato around third
he will score
and andrew vaughn has a two rbi single
the sox score the first two of the game
lamb the dh for the white sox tonight
smith brings the first one to jake it's
a fly ball
deep right center
this is gone
three-run shot for jake lamb
and the white sox jump out to a 5-0 lead
on oakland
this will bring up the shortstop elvis
andrus
the one-two from lopez cut the miss
got him on a slider
lopez goes cleanly through the order
first time through
strikeout there number one of the night
white sox lead it 5-0
and that will bring up matt olson
sox lead at five nothing top of the
fourth lopez deals the o2 pitch
collins frames it called strike three
great breaking ball from lopez
and olson out for looking
jose abreu is batting three tonight he's
over two smith set here's the 2-1 pitch
high fly ball left field harrison back
at the wall he'll jump and this is over
the fence
jose abreu with a three-run shot to left
and the white sox leaded eight to
nothing
matt chapman will start the fifth inning
for the a's they trail eight nothing
everybody back on the infield against
the a's third baseman lopez goes into
the motion the o2 called strike three
right over the middle with a 97 mile an
hour fastball
and chapman will just wander back to the
a's bench set down looking and it brings
up sean murphy the catcher another 2-2
swing and a miss got him on a slider it
backed up on murphy and he didn't have a
chance lopez is jacked up walking off
the mound
he's through five and
scoreless
white sox leading eight to nothing
[Applause]
first pitch by burr is up the middle
from olson anderson steps on second
throws over the first great double play
by tim anderson from an all-star this
year for the first time silver slugger
award last year and he hit 3 22. 3 35
and 19 to lead the majors 3-2 anderson
cracks one into left center field this
will get down for a hit past the left
fielder harrison collins being waved
around third anderson around second he's
in on a slide pollen scores in the white
sox lead nine to nothing so here's
eloy jimenez this single fly to center
bounced as short nine nothing chicago
two out bottom of the six on the south
side deekman the fourth athletic to fish
tonight and throws and it's the ground
ball left side taking it short elvis has
it put to first for the out the ending
is over for six white sox nine athletics
nothing
and mitch moreland's gonna pitch for the
a's
here's zach collins lefty on lefty the
2-2 on the way swung out or miss throws
it by him a fastball here's the pitch
now and it's a swing and a fly ball
right center playable under it brown is
there he makes to get a great job by
moreland
that was some pitching and we go to the
ninth and it's nine nothing in chicago
it'll bring up tony kemp attempts 0 for
one there's the o2
ground ball left side mendix got it
throw over the first gets him
and the white sox take two in a row from
the oakland a's